une convention vient d'être signée entre
la cpam des yvelines et les restos du
coeur une concrétisation officielle qui
s'inscrit dans la continuité si le
partenariat était informelle les deux
entités travaillent en collaboration
depuis plusieurs années l'association
dispose d'un rôle essentiel identifiés
et accompagner des personnes éloignées
du système de santé
les restos du coeur connaissent bien les
familles qui les accompagnent et en fait
elles vont pouvoir nous aider
à détecter parce que les personnes n'ont
pas forcément envie de raconter leurs
problèmes auprès d'une institution un
besoin qui s'est fait ressentir 30% des
personnes renonceraient à des soins sur
une période d'un an au centre des restos
du coeur de plaisir ils sont une dizaine
de bénévoles à être formés à l'aide à la
personne c'est le cas de françois
bénévole depuis une vingtaine d'années
il a suivi la formation en octobre
c'était beaucoup basé sur la
complémentaire santé solidaire on a
régulièrement et je pense qu'on va en
refaire encore avec des formateurs de
formateurs de l'acceptable pour
apprendre de nouveaux bénévoles qui se
sentent concernées qu'elles sont comment
fonctionne la sepa et pour connaître le
fonctionnement de la cpam l'institution
a présenté ces dispositifs aux bénévoles
que ce soit l'accès au droit les
complémentaires santé solidaire et la
mission non moi je m'occupe
d'accompagnement en santé et la
concrètement nos équipes vont aller
directement sur le terrain auprès des
bénévoles pour les accompagner les
formés à la détection les former ou un
différents dispositifs qui existent dans
l'assurance maladie l'année dernière
près de 1300 personnes ont été
accompagnées dans les yvelines